[Musik]
wie es so läuft ist nicht hab ich mal
nachgefragt ob sich das dann theoretisch
auch lohnt weißt du für dich extra
rüberzukommen leute alters mit der sonne
jetzt hier ich weiß nicht ob ich das gut
finden sondern war schlecht sonst ganz
schön ja was ist das überstrahlt mein
gesicht deswegen finde ich auch gut
trotz top und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen bio jahr wollte ich hoffe
natürlich geld gut heute ist wieder
freitag und ich weiß jetzt würde ich
noch dran erinnern kann es letzten
freitag haben auch ein video schon mit
uns online bis freitag ist unser lied
das habe ich nämlich gerade gedacht das
könnte man theoretisch machen das jeden
freitag ein video mit meiner freundin
kommt ich muss ich vielleicht erst ich
muss mich vielleicht erst mal ganz kurz
entschuldigen für das letzte video weil
ich habe gesehen da standen sehr viele
kommentare zu mir dass ich total
gemeinden zu marie ich habe mir die
stellen dann noch mal angeguckt und ich
muss sagen ich kann das verstehen dass
das da stand aber aus einem grund weil
ich danach nie gesagt habe also wirklich
gesagt hat das ist spaß war zum beispiel
so dieses dass ich mir nicht vorstellen
kann mit dir länger zusammen zu sein
weil es sind das war echt ein bisschen
dumm macht wie zb weiß dass das halt
spaß ist so und sagen mir kam das auch
ganz so also ich fahre auch nicht sauer
oder so nachdem wir das video gedreht
haben und dann habe ich nachher so die
kommentare gelesen nein leute also ich
bin eigentlich glaube ich ganz nett zu
ihr
deswegen tut mir das ein bisschen leid
und da versuche ich jetzt ein bisschen
mehr drauf zu achten sich nicht immer so
zu bett zu dissen
naja aber wir schon mal was das heutige
video so bringt okay wir haben uns
nämlich heute war es extrem
spektakuläres überlebt eigentlich wollte
ich so was nie machen
naja ich das ein bisschen schon zu gast
wenn du das ist ein bisschen zu privates
hier sag ich mal
aber wir sind jetzt mittlerweile schon
so lange zusammen und ich kann jetzt
sagen dass die latte ist man zwar ist
ein sehr bekanntes format von vielen
juden die das schon gemacht haben
die ersten jets zeigen
und bei uns sehen es aber um instagram
schätzen weil wir haben bei im sommer
geschrieben so und da ist jetzt auch
nicht also es ist schon lustig es ist
jetzt aber jetzt nichts schlimmes dabei
was meiner meinung nach zu privat ist
deswegen checken wir jetzt mal ab und ja
eigentlich relativ fische kennenlernen
zg mal ein bisschen weiter rüber weil
dann können wir den chat genau jetzt zu
schneiden würden während barrios' hochs
gold kann ich vielleicht noch eine kurze
story dazu erzählen und zwar wann war
das 2017 oder so ne also vor zwei oder
vor drei jahren schon fast ne ja also
eigentlich ist mir das auch ein bisschen
unangenehm weil ich will lächelt immer
so diese was heißt belächelt also ich
find das irgend ein bisschen komisch
wenn man sich über instagram
kennenlernen und dann auch irgendwann so
zusammen ist bei uns war es so wir haben
irgendwann mal über install
angeschrieben und danach waren wir mal
oder meine eltern sind immer auf den
balearen im urlaub und marie war auch
auf ibiza und das war ziemlich nah
aneinander und ich habe halt so gefolgt
und haben sind wir ins gespräch gekommen
und dann haben wir beschlossen dass wir
uns da mal treffen so sei das halt
zufall war dass wir am gleichen
urlaubsort waren und dadurch haben wir
uns dann praktisch kennen gelernt also
man kann schon sagen dass der erste
kontakt über instagram mal stattgefunden
hat aber es wäre niemals zu einem
treffen gekommen wenn wir nicht am
gleichen urlaubsort gewesen werden also
ich würde sagen ich lese jetzt erstmal
den ersten kontakt vor und dann kannst
du gleich den zweiten also dann vorlesen
wir uns dann praktisch im urlaub
getroffen haben was ich meine
also ich habe geschrieben haye am 8 mai
2017 also ich habe geschrieben hat
zugeschrieben haider und ich geschrieben
schöne fotos dann hast du geschrieben
vielen lieben dank hab ich geschrieben
gerne habe ich gefragt sonst alles gut
ja und bei dir
naja hab noch drei stunden uni sonst
schon was studierst du dann bla bla bla
bla bla bla also eigentlich so ein
bisschen langweilig also um ehrlich zu
sein macht das studium nur damit meine
eltern zufrieden sind aber es ist okay
hast du geschrieben aber eigentlich war
das gar nicht so obwohl ich weiß gar
nicht mehr was ich mir dabei gedacht
haben ich wollte sie auf cool machen
aber es ist schon schlau und studium zu
haben deswegen studiert ja auch immer
noch dann hast du geschrieben habe auch
so was wie das bei mir auch hinauslaufen
redest du noch zur schule
neben jetzt fertig ok und so weiter das
ist ja ein bisschen langweilig aha
moment mal kurz jetzt habe hier
folgendes gesehen du hast mir nämlich
dann als erstes geschrieben als ich im
urlaub beim er sagt es ist ja das weiß
ich ja bei alex und ich uns nach diesem
gespräch gefolgt haben wir haben aber
wie lange war dass wir lange gekämpft
hatten
northeim monat 100 haben wir halt sogar
sollten bis ende juni juli an die 2 ich
habe bei diesem problem das problem mit
juni/juli kann sich so auseinander
halten wäre auf jeden fall zwei monate
gar nicht mehr geschrieben auszufallen
wer weiter wie gesagt auf ibiza
formentera
und dann hab ich die initiative
ergriffen weil wir uns nach diesem
gespräch befolgt haben gegenseitig und
immer nur so die stories gegenseitig
glaube ich erfreut haben so ein bisschen
habe ich die initiative ergriffen und
gefragt ob er nicht lust hat ja du musst
die ganze welt hey du hast du jetzt
schon alles verraten du kannst es auch
hier am vorlesen du du mir gibst hat so
genau jetzt kommt der kette dann als
zweites gefolgt hat da habe ich habe
geschrieben ibiza waren mit jesus 2 hier
sind wir wirklich nie
ja ich wollte so cool sollen ja dann
hast du geschrieben bis auch hier oder
so als ob du es nicht wüsste
obwohl ich schon fünf tage da war und
jeden tag neues gemacht haben schon noch
ein bisschen weil darüber dann habe ich
geschrieben jetzt dann hast du
geschrieben geil geil geil
also ich war vor einem monat auf ibiza
bin ist aber gerade meinen eltern auf
formentera denke ich kann man danach
darüber hat man dafür schon wieder
geflachst da hab ich gesagt dass ich
schon mal da war vor einem monat um
jetzt wieder da bin ich aber ich war das
war wirklich so aber ich war erst mit
freunden da so ein bisschen party machen
dabei nämlich gerade 18 oder 18
wahrscheinlich 18 oder so und da war ich
halt schon drei tage da und meine eltern
weil die halt immer dann fand also ich
kann mich da aus wie in meiner
eigenen hosentasche neben westentasche
tschuldigung war ich halt dann wieder da
doch weil meine eltern passt auch dass
zugeschrieben denke ich habe meine nacht
drüber wahrscheinlich solche
anspielungen dass wir unser treffen
könnten
dann hab ich die nächste anhörung ops
treffen im achter abgeschrieben morgen
ist martin garrigues im hitze da gehen
wir hin aber dienstagabend fliegen wir
auch leider schon zurück also habe ich
quasi gar keine andere chance gegeben
am dienstag rüber zu kommen aber ich hab
so und ich habe mir dann wirklich so ich
habe dann überlegt ob ich da ob ich
jetzt wirklich mal rüber fahren sollen
dann habe ich mir gedacht ja wenn du
dann rüber vers dann macht es ja auch
sinn wenn du da irgendwann kennt wobei
ich auch sagen muss ich war letztes jahr
weil das war jetzt 2017 und im jahr 2009
10 war ich auch wieder bei meinen eltern
eine woche und bin dann alleine rüber
gefallen und war ein und macht einfach
alleine auf ibiza unterwegs zu die ganze
nacht ganz allein ich habe alleine was
bevor wir drucken im hotel so einfach
man so ja ich glaube ich gehe wenn dann
dienstag in sosua ja das dachte ich mir
so brach weil ich bestimmten tiefe
fahren wir wieder nach hause
sagst du geschrieben okay ich habe vier
wände auf dienstag ist so schwach so
genau das war einem hotel da wollte
immer schon mal hin und da bin ich aber
noch nie hingekommen aus als letztes
jahr da war ich einmal doch dann hast du
noch hinzugefügt war letztens im hey das
war nicht so mein ding also natürlich
geil war viel zu früh ist ja auch
gefährlich nur das kann tödlich enden
oder hast du ja dann hab ich geschrieben
oder hast du geschrieben aber es wird
schon gut wenn martin garrigues da es
wahrscheinlich wenn ich die freude ist
in hilter vorgeschrieben das ist scheiße
also wenn auch ich war nämlich schon mal
und das war echt nicht gut beim ersten
mal wo ich da was ja okay jetzt wird man
hier etwas haben wir noch nie gemacht
aber dann hast du geschrieben
bist du einfach so urlaubs mäßig auf
ibiza oder morgen
ach genau weil dann stand auf dem profil
liegen wie das model bist und ich kann
ja jetzt nicht einschätzen ob das
wirklich so es gibt ja dann einmal die
mädels die das dahin schreiben und dann
einmal im jahr
irgendwie so einen kleinen job haben und
das model sind und es gibt ja welche die
das wirklich professionell und auch
vielleicht sogar hauptberuflich machen
und ich wusste jetzt nicht bei ihr wie
es so läuft ist
nachgefragt ob sich das dann theoretisch
auch lohnt weißt du für dich extra
rüberzukommen
hey und hat sein sonst geht ja oder nein
also wir haben uns nur nicht unterhalten
und so und du hast ja auch noch eine
freundin dabei ja genau darauf kommen
wir jetzt selber gesagt nein nur so mit
einer freundin und ich wusste ja auch am
anfang noch nicht bin jetzt von beiden
nicht mehr auf suche meinen spaß sagte
focus wir müssen mal in köln feier jetzt
sag du mal bitte dass mit diesem modul
und mir einen schlafplatz angeboten muss
das ist nämlich noch ganz lustig da hast
du kriegen ja aber auch mega anstrengend
ich meine ich muss dann morgens mit der
fähre wieder nach formentera genau das
musste ich nämlich echt dann habe ich
also ich will das noch nichts verraten
formentera ist hier neben insel dafür
hat man so eine halbe stunde hin also
das sind praktisch zwei inseln die
relativ nah beieinander liegen
genau und dann hab ich geschrieben wir
haben in unserem hotelzimmer ein
wohnzimmer kann es auf der ausziehbaren
gehabt klappt laut couch schlafen h und
da dachte ich mir wie so einige minuten
zugeschrieben ist ja lief mit dach oder
zumindest genau und dann habe ich
nämlich überlegt ob ich das wirklich
machen soll diesmal modell ist so
geschrieben dass der vorschlag von
meiner freundin kann man auch wirklich
was dann wirklich der fall noch so ja
ich muss mal schauen hat es aber eine
nette freundin ja die ist sehr nett ja
schon einfach mal ja mach ich ich muss
jetzt erstmal im schlaf nachholen
wünsche euch viel spaß wie auch immer
ihr hingeht dankeschön schlaf gut und
warte mal war das dann am 16 wo wir
geschrieben haben kommen dann habe ich
dir nämlich am 17 also einen tag danach
geschrieben
hay habe gerade mal geschaut was die
woche auf ibiza ist und wenn dann würde
ich echt heute muss nur noch meine
eltern überzeugen damit die nicht
traurig sind dass ich heute abend nicht
mit essen kommen
wollten sie um 10 los und ja vorher
schon was trinken habt nur noch ein
prozent akku sagen die da so um 37 noch
mal bescheid dazu weil wir waren immer
am strand an den ganzen tag und da hast
du dann irgendwann keinen abbruch
dann hast du erstmal nummer geklärt
genau dann habe ich noch geschrieben
wird es mir wohl deine nummer geben ist
einfach wegen stand und so
ja und dann war das eigentlich so alles
war schon ganz lustig und wir haben
jetzt auch mal die website schätz
versucht noch zu finden aber das problem
ist sie hat ein neues handy und ich habe
auch nicht mehr die ersten hätte und ja
dann haben wir uns halt irgendwann auch
mal so in köln getroffen weil ich ja
dann auch hier gewohnt habe und sie gar
nicht mal so weit von hier weg wohnen
also es ist schon stück immer aber noch
lustige story zu dem abend in ibiza dass
mir letztens wieder angefangen habe ich
mit einer freundin darüber geredet
da kam so ein trip zu mir und habe mich
irgendwie so angemacht und so und alex
meine freundin die stadt dann so möchte
ich dabei und dann habe ich gesagt nee
nee das ist mein freund und hab deine
hand genommen und dann hast du gesagt ja
und dann ist der weg gegangen weil ein
solcher vorgang ja leute also das war es
eigentlich auch schon
ich hoffe das war ganz unterhaltsam und
mehr möchte ich auch jetzt dazu gar
nicht dann vorlesen oder so glaube das
ist schon ganz lustig also für uns ist
auf jeden fall immer lustig daran
zurückdenken soll ich mal wir hoffen
natürlich dass hat euch gefallen dass du
nach oben da instagram ist hier
eingeblendet und dann sehen wir uns am
sonntag wieder da gibt es nämlich um 19
uhr das nächste video und auf meinem
kanal da wieder selbst wahrscheinlich in
einem jahr also leute danke für
zuschauer ein